gibt es gerechtigkeit im hollywoodkino
schon denn zum schluss der sheriff den
bösewicht abführt aber im richtigen
leben ist es meist zum verzweifeln wenn
blutrünstige mörderbanden bestialisch
ihre geiseln umbringen wenn despotische
alleinherrscher ganze länder kaputt
machen
und niemand kann oder will etwas tun
selbst wenn wir jetzt in syrien
millionen menschen aufs bitterste
darunter leiden gibt es gerechtigkeit
das lähmung der verzweiflung keineswegs
die einzige antwort sein muss auf diese
frage das spürte ich deutlich als ich
vor kurzem die frau einen vortrag halten
hörte die jahre lang wie ein sheriff für
die uno strafgerichte ganz großen
übeltätern der weltpolitik nachgestellt
hat und davon
mit so viel leidenschaft und feuer in
den augen erzählt hat dass ich sie bat
sofort nach der syrien mission von der
sie eben zurück kommt bei uns her im
studio vorbei zu schauen
carla del ponte bevor wir zu syrien
kommen was mich an ihrem vortrag so
gepackt hat war wie sie den kampf für
gerechtigkeit als beharrliches handwerk
dargestellt haben und als einer der noch
nie einen bad guy verhört hat frage ich
sie schüttelt man einem mafiaboss oder
einem mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrecher die
handelt wenn man in den verhörraum
reinkommt ich muss sagen dass ich nie
die hand hin gegeben habe denn natürlich
weiß ich
um was es geht und welche kriminelle
verantwortung sie haben also kommt bei
mir nicht aber natürlich wenn sie die
hand ausstrecken und das kann er hat den
ganzen prima vor java oder so war sehr
höflich oder doch die strecke in die
hand und dann gebe ich die hand also
genauso wie zum beispiel habe ich nicht
die hand gestreckt und der rat auch
nicht die handgestrickt muss ich sage
dagegen der mafiaboss toto riina
[Musik]
hat hat die hand gestreckt und er hat
sogar eine entschuldigung ausgesagt in
dem ich eine lange reise machen musste
um ihn zu besuchen
aber sie glaubt neben kein wort davon
dieser höflichkeit natürlich nicht denn
den das werde das war absolut typisch
mafioso nicht aber die da konnte ich
natürlich die hand nicht welche
atmosphäre in einem verhör raum müssen
sie anstreben müssen sie ein bisschen
furchteinflößend wirken damit sie
respektiert werden unfreundlich stoff
oder kann man es auch auf die sanfte
tour versuchen
man musste in den ersten drei minuten
der begegnung wissen wie man anpacken
muss manchmal muss man halt manchmal
muss man eben als in funktion des typs
der partie gesagt
man muss einfach wissen wie man die die
einvernahmen einpacken muss und das ist
sehr wichtig denn nachher geht es geht
es ziemlich gut aber wenn sie diesen
moment verpassen dann dann ist es fußt
ja und dann nach 20 minuten würden sie
auf den sie wie sie spüren dass es nicht
geht aber das ist auch eine wahre
verfahrens mäßig nicht deshalb ich dann
lieben jahren gut gelernt wird sich
zeigen
und warum wollten sie nicht die
höflichkeit formel des hand reichen zu
machen hatten sie wirklich abscheu vor
diesen menschen ja das ist es
das ist es besonders bei den
kriegsverbrechen da wirklich ist es ist
etwas unglaubliches
und wenn sie in kontakt mit den opfern
haben mit den überlebenden nicht
das macht dann ein kontrast und dann
plötzlich kommt hinein
gut gekleidet wie wenn er wie er nicht
aus einem gefängnis kommen will bei der
von einem 50 hotels nicht und und er
gibt die hand so also
so etwas passiert und man man nimmt sie
sagen ich habe ich muss sagen ich habe
immer sofort nach hände gewaschen als
hannah arendt damals die philosophin
über den eichmann-prozess in israel
berichtet hat und dem den titel die
banalität des bösen gegeben hat hat das
riesige diskussionen ausgelöst ob man
einen schreibtisch mörder wiechmann
banal nennen durfte ich frage sie nicht
nach der banalität des bösen auch nach
der banalität der bösen sind die
irgendwie banal gewöhnliche leute oder
spürt man eine abgrundtiefe im bau seien
eben aussehen sind sie gewöhnliche leute
normale leute aber wenn sie mit diesen
leuten sprechen dann spüren sie spüren
sie wie die ideologie in den meisten
fällen kriegsverbrechen
diese ideologie zu etwas grausam
geworden ist und darf verstehen sie dass
sie über die limite gegangen sind etwas
das überhaupt nicht
nicht
eingenommen werden kann aber nicht die
täter verstehen ist selber oder gibt es
ansatz von roy leisten nicht nein ich
glaube nur einen täter hat es bereut und
er hat dann das sony zieht gemacht wie
bei uns im ex jugoslawien tribunal aber
sonst die anderen überhaupt keine
überhaupt kein ich erinnere mich sehr
gut die bilder platz sieht sie hat sogar
versucht mich zu überzeugen wie die
serben eine höhere ethnie sind als die
hand hat die hatte die ideologie
wirklich eingebrannt offenbar ja das
bringt nicht im vergleich zu mafiosi zur
spekulativen frage weil ich die nur aus
den filmen wie der pate und so kenne
ob die dann böse sind im sinn um die
statisten sind die gerne menschen ins
wasser werfen und den betonpfeilern
versenkt ist ein unterschied zwischen
dem mafioso der wirklich persönlich böse
ist nicht nur ideologie gesteuert etwas
ganz anderes präzise interessen
ökonomische interessen also es gibt um 9
paul aber im aussehen und in kontakt
sind sehr nett und ich spüre nicht diese
wiese dass sie böse sind oder sie
grausam sie überhaupt nicht dagegen bei
denen kriegsverbrechen eben im gespräch
spüren sie wie sie diese unglaubliche
unglaubliche auffassung natürlich nicht
kriminelle als jetzt sind sie mitglied
einer kommission die im auftrag der uno
die situation in syrien in diesem
schrecklichen bürgerkrieg untersucht sie
kommen eben aus der gegend zurück ich
stelle mir vor es ist doch schwierig sie
können ja nicht zu assad dem syrischen
herrscher einfach hingehen und sagen
hier bin ich als abhören sie auf ihr
volk so zu können würde ich gern tun
nicht vor allem das heft mit albums
nicht die diese bomben sind
sind zerstörerisch das nicht ein
bisschen nicht geboren sind in der sind
bomben wo sie verschiedene explosiv
verschiedene materialien hinein tun und
und das kann ein gebäude zerstören ich
bin wie sie mit diesen bomben und das
wirken sie so was sagte zwar bin ich
noch nicht gekommen habe keinen zugang
wir haben zugang zu serien so erstmal
ich muss sagen die regierung serien hat
mich persönlich eingeladen aber den mal
meine personalkapazität also nur als ja
so nicht mitglied der kommission und und
machen sie wenn sie nicht gegangen
die kommission hat entschieden und ich
einverstanden dass sie der sich gehen
oder wenn nicht als comic serie gehen
kann und was ist der unterschied von
außerhalb aus gesehen sehr politisch ist
es ein großer unterschied für mich nicht
der peripherie weil dann anerkennt die
kommission wenn er sie aus kommission
vertreten
aber jetzt und das ist das wolle man
sehen
ich habe ich habe den syrischen
botschafter getroffen und ich habe ihm
gesagt wenn die einladung auch steht
bin ich bereit zu gehen und man sehen
was können sie doch bewirken kann man
einem diktator ins gewissen
nein das schiff das für dich nicht
einmal versuchen
ich weiß es ist nichts bringt arbeitet
wissen sie wenn sie ihre mieten ist es
wichtig dass sie 63 grad und mädchen
können und das heißt ich muss auch die
beweise sammeln die sie haben die zeit
diese jungs wurde gestellt haben aber
nicht gegeben habe und ich muss
natürlich und mein leute in der
kommission mission bereits sein
einvernahmen durchzuführen das wäre am
besten
dort würden sie die sicht die vorwürfe
die die regierungsseite in syrien an die
opposition richtet auflisten und so ja
und vor allem wenn sie denken an die
chemischen waffen nicht wir wissen heute
noch nicht wie die chemischen waffen
benutzt hat wir haben einige indizien
aber eigentlich können wir sagen den
dietzen sind auf beide seiten nicht also
wissen wir noch nicht sie vermuten beide
seiten haben ein gesetz passieren hat
gesagt sie hat diese chemischen waffen
nicht nicht gebraucht also bitteschön
kommt mit beweisen denn nicht und wir
müssen doch an ort und stelle arbeiten
können nicht und ich wäre ich bin sehr
neugierig darüber um zu wissen wer was
gebraucht hat den sehr wahrscheinlich
haben beide seiten chemische waffen
das kennzeichnet sie ja dass sie in
allen konflikten wo sie untersucht haben
nicht nur auf eine richtung geschaut
haben sich damit geopolitisch nicht
immer freunde freude freunde gemacht
haben
im kosovo zum beispiel auch gegen die
udk die näher beim besten vorher
untersucht haben
ist das einfach ihre tiefe überzeugung
wenn man schon dort ist und auch wenn
man denkt der haupttäter sitzt hier
man muss auch die kleinen eben täter
immer auf dem radar haben ja man muss
einfach die volle wahrheit wissen nicht
also dass das ihre miete nicht also die
fakten die die objektiven fakten und und
natürlich man muss sie mir auf was sind
das die politik hinein hineinspielt und
das ist besonders auf dem
internationalen niveau spielen sie mich
nicht dass die politik sich an mich aber
die kommen immer wieder stelle ich mir
vor
die politik ist sie mir da den wir
brauchen den politischen willen
ermitteln zu können um diese prozesse
durchzuführen aber die politik muss an
der türe in der justiz halten nicht was
ich tue sie aber nicht wenn wir syrien
haben sehen kann man nicht ziemlich
simpel sagen russland dem falle putin
der dort das sagen hat beschützt assad
und darum ist gegen assad nichts zu
machen
ich weiß nicht du bist du nicht was ich
weiß ist dass der sicherheitsrat keinen
entscheid treffen kann
denn eben russland vetorecht
aber auf der anderen seite die die
opponenten nennen wie sie so sind sie
auch unterstützt von aus von auswärts
nähert und es gibt
amerika es gibt saudi arabien es gab da
so viele andere länder die dabei helfen
es gibt sogar eine koalition jetzt und
haben sie türkei die türkei ist ein
offenes land jede die die waffen gehen
und kommen von der türkei herein in
serien und die die vorne fighters die
die fremden
wie sagt man fremden der förderung sind
die können hinein also türkei spielt
eine schlechte rolle hier nicht und das
hört nicht auf und wir hoffen jetzt mit
dem letzten bericht unser mandat unser
mandat endet jetzt markt wir hoffen dass
mit unserem bericht doch etwas zustande
contento politischer entscheid für eine
politische lösung dieses konflikts und
vor allem dass die staaten dass die
internationale gemeinschaft etwas tut
denn bis jetzt sind es wirklich sind
jetzt wirklich nur noch krieg und opfert
sie haben flüchtlingslager mehr als zehn
millionen serien die alles verloren
haben mehr als drei millionen sind haben
zilien wird lassen die anderen sind im
säbel haben nichts mehr also denken sie
mal was das bedeutet also wir sind wir
sind dran zu dulden dass der syrische
staat dieser bild verschwindet von der
bildfläche und millionen von leuten die
schilder nicht leiden
sie waren ja mit dieser mission schon
unterwegs und hatten schon im vorfeld
der letzten mission jetzt gesagt syrien
ist noch schlimmer als vieles was sie
gesehen haben uns haben vieles gesehen
was sehr schlimm war ja ich meine bei
den folter wie sie foltern ist es
unglaublich die folgen sehr lange damit
der tod sehr spät eintritt nicht wahllos
ehrlichkeit das spiel ja dann weiß ich
es gibt noch kein tribunal es gibt noch
kein prosecutors diese diese
die angeklagten und verdächtigen sind
noch nicht eingenommen wird aber ich
habe gelesen ist im juni tätigte
man kann machen was man will und
riskiert im moment nichts aber ich habe
gelesen
sie machen listen sie haben in einem
tresor irgendwo listen von tätern
ja wir haben diese liste das ist jetzt
die vierstellig sste die wir haben
werden man sehen was wir machen mit
dieser liest er nicht denn da müssen wir
da auch an den für die opfer
ich will ja mit ihnen ein bisschen
erforschen wie man gerechtigkeit
herstellen kann handwerklich was man
machen muss was funktioniert und was
nicht funktioniert und da wäre eine
frage natürlich was muss man für ein typ
sein um an der front der internationalen
strafgericht zu wirken und da fand ich
es interessant in ihrer biografie ist
eine überlegung einmal zu lesen sie
waren ein mädchen das wie pandas
giftschlangen gefangen hat sie waren
eine wippe sängerin warum haben sie
damals wittmann gejagt im tessin aus
kind ja dass das habe ich in meinem buch
geschrieben ich wollte das eigentlich
nicht aber der 6
mit diesem buch geschrieben nein bringen
wir das sein was warum haben wir das
gemacht nicht aus abenteuer und
natürlich bei dem fanden der wepad und
das zweite war der business den 50
schweizer franken damals für eine die
privat natürlich wenn man acht neun
jahre alt ist sehr viel geld also weil
sie konnten die in einem laboratorium
die dann das gift oder regierung gemacht
haben verkaufen und das hatten sie keine
angst beim fangen somit stecken dann auf
den namen eigentlich nicht da beide
haben schon die impfungen dabei die im
von renault trucks hätten sie hat genau
das hatten wir ist und dann mussten sie
die aber im zug ins labor bringen jetzt
warum das für reisen ja das war ich ging
sowieso von mias gemeinde dann nach
locarno mit dem zug und klavierstunden
zu haben nicht und dann
diese diese kartonschachtel
schuhschachtel dabei und natürlich haben
wir ein loch gemacht damit die
beratungen kann sagt das natürlich blöd
eigentlich unter der woche war das loch
war zu groß und sie wollte raus also
musste sie beim schon bei der zweiten
reihe und ich habe sie einfach immer
zurück nicht getraut aus kommen lassen
sagt man der zugführer hat gesehen was
hast du da und ich habe gesagt dass ich
hatte und dann unsere business war
fertig denn er hat meine muntere inside
me und einmal das wetter oder schlangen
haben so fertigen ja nein aber sie haben
andere tätigkeiten gefunden wie sie
interessiert haben dann haben sie jus
studiert und sie sind scheidungsanwältin
geworden war das intro geworden denn ich
habe angefangen mit richtig man musste
zwei jahren ein bisschen anders machen
zwei jahre lang gemischt und ja ich habe
ich habe viele scheidungen und ich hab
da bricht hatte sie nicht gern aber ich
habe gekämpft gekämpft und die sauen
damit sie geld die genug bekommen usw
also schon für die gerechtigkeit
gekämpft damit es werden mir ein
bisschen langweilig diese sowieso kampf
an so unternahm ich einen aneinander dem
ganz getroffen sie haben auch noch ein
paar kleinkriminelle oder so verteidigt
das musste ich auch ja das war
obligatorisch aber werde ich habe ich
nämlich wenn ich ins gefängnis
hinausgehen und mit dem angeklagten
gesprochen haben und und ich habe sie
gelesen na ja die jetzt diese müssten
sie einfach zugeben dass wir es gemacht
da bin sondern hat mich immer wieder
bezieht sie meinen verteidigen
trotzdem spucken und und was was wollen
wir da machen nicht also ich war ein
sehr schlechtes ich sagen bin ich
bereitete ihm staatsanwalt über unter
andere seite gesessen
ich wollte dort setzt sitzen und dann
mit der zeit bin ich doch so weit
gekommen aber nehmen
damals das war mir ein männerberuf nicht
und und backwaren nicht so leicht von
anfang nein sie ist dadurch zu setzen
ein denn wenn etwas mal dass man
einstellen
die stelle bekam aber dann muss ich
sagen dann war es schnell vorbei den
mann hat meine kollegen nahmen gespielt
das ist es ist eine schlange empfängerin
die kann auch keine schwierigkeiten dass
das magnet ist dann das weiß ich auch
aus ihrem buch war ist fast ein bisschen
zufällig dass sie als jüngste im team
staatsanwältin dort die mafia
spezialistin geworden sind weil
plötzlich ein italienischer kollege
vorbeischaut im tessin
er stimmt er stimmte zwar richte falcone
nicht wann er hat seine seine
wir suchen geschickt und dann ist
gekommen er hatte dort gesagt hat
kämmerer denn normalerweise kommen die
ausländische richter nicht habe ehre
hatte gesagt das käme und dann natürlich
an unsere sitzungen sind ja werden wenn
beschäftigt sich mit ihm nicht und
niemand wollte denn es ist ein zeit
verwandeln es ist nicht mein fall ist
ein verfahren im ausland also angesagt
endpunkte du bist die letzte die
gekommenen die sonst so machst du das
und das war für mich ein ein glück ein
unglaubliches professionellen
menschlichen und persönlichen glück dass
ich ihn getroffen haben wir sind gerade
alle diese ermittlungen durch gemachten
zusagen an gespürt das ist ein
doch ausnahmen welt ist doch unglaublich
aber und natürlich sehen wir schon
einmal einen ganzen tag zusammen gesetzt
und ich habe wir müssen sagen für
jüngere menschen die uns anschauen und
sich nicht mehr an die news die
schlimmen news mit denen ist dann
geändert hat für ihn gesehen haben er
war der staatsanwalt in italien der
mutigsten gegen die mafia vorgegangen
ist ja was war es ein dossier genau er
hat in palermo man gern reitet er hatte
alle ermittlungen eröffnet gegen die
mafiosi und natürlich waren unter
lebensgefahr
aber er hat nie nachgelassen und am
schluss jedoch getötet worden mit einem
sprengstoffanschlag im internet von
paletten machte auf einer autobahn die
man quasi anwendungen gesprengt hat da
war kein überleben möglichen als er kam
haben sie gespürt das ist ein
außergewöhnlicher mensch auch sie geben
in der biografie sogar zu dass sie
damals ihr bonbon für südländische macho
typen entdeckt haben nicht ausfällt habe
ihm gefallen
doch doch doch immer sympathischer und
und ich habe viel von ihm gelernt wie
man einen film nimmt den normalerweise
hätte ich ein vernehmen sind eines
jahres war wie eine medizin aber ich
habe ihn gebeten doch wie einvernahme
durchzuführen denn es waren ja da seine
ermittlungen
und da habe ich etliche bekommen
professionell wie man ware gut richtigen
er was erzählen
und dann muss man das machen raffinesse
was man sagt es senkt davon haben die
ersten minuten
aber das habe ich von ihm gelernt war er
ein mensch ohne angst ich meine in
italien in palermo sich die ganze mafia
zum frank machen
das ist keine über lebensrezept
versichert er hatte einen großen mut
aber wissen sie immer man wächst hinein
von heute zu morgen wendig mutig das ist
etwas das langsam langsam langsam
nicht ich hätte auch nie gedacht dass
ich dass ich so weit komme nicht ich
habe mich in lugano gesehen als
staatsanwalt das war für mich mein höhe
professionellen punkt da wird sie sehen
dann es ist ganz anders geworden aber
gut das macht man aber sie sind dann mit
ihm zusammen
zeitweise auch nach palermo gegangen da
war auch risiko dabei ja wir sind
mehrere male hat er mich telefoniert du
kannst nicht kommen es ist zu gefährlich
kommt es nicht auch nicht auf einmal war
es soweit ist wer da habe ich im jahre
und da sind wir auch einen einen
anschlag entkommen entkommen
wenn das war am abend vorher aber wäre
zu nachgegeben
in einem restaurant und der hat nämlich
gesagt morgen sind wir fertig und so
kommt ihr ich habe ein haus vermietet
wurde am meer können wir dort war denn
ich habe nicht nein oder ja gesagt ich
habe mich nicht geäußert dabei am
anderen tag im büro
aber ich ihm gesagt sie ist das jetzt
jemand der sich in palermo wenig möchte
palermo besucher macht es dir nichts
wenn ich nicht mehr er hat mir gesagt da
sehr gut sind aber sind wahrscheinlich
im restaurant jemand hat die information
weitergegeben und es war eine badetasche
mit 6 56 kilo explosiv dort nicht und
das haben sie natürlich entdeckt wir
sind nicht dort gegangen ist da auch
nicht dort geben aber es hätte schief
gehen ist etc steht haben sie damals
keine angst als junge staatsanwältin war
im moment wo sie die informationen
bekommen haben sie angst natürlich denn
sie denken oh dear aber dann sind sie
froh dass es dann noch mehrmals passiert
nicht aber im moment natürlich sind sind
sie ein bisschen bleiben sie ein
bisschen atemloser wäre eine sekunde und
nachher sagen sie halt ob es nicht
gegangen also umso besser ist eine alles
gute muss man vielleicht auch ein
bisschen ambitiös sein also mit viel er
viel feind viel ehr sagt man auf deutsch
wenn man sich in die gefahr begibt hat
man natürlich auch bewunderung haben sie
auch nach dieser bewunderung entweder
gesucht oder waren dankbar wenn dann sie
zeigen konnten ich bin nicht so ein
durchschnitts staatsanwalt maßnahme
ambitiös sie hier muss man sein aber
nicht in diese hinsicht ambitiöses dass
die angeklagte verhaftet und verurteilt
werden das schon
ich erinnere mich an die verhaftung
milosevic nicht so das sind mal ambitiös
daher nicht wir haben damals
gefeiert denn so viele solcher minister
in der öffentlichkeit nicht sagen aber
war nicht zu handeln
dann haben wir einen schlechten roten
beinen gehabt aber dafür die für die
anderen beratung haben wird schon noch
champagner
denn das ist ambitiös professionell
ambitiös aber nicht für sich selber für
sich selbst die gewalt nein ich würde
nicht ich habe nie so etwas im empfangen
ein
es ist wirklich nur dieser wille dass
man doch dass man sich nicht zurückzieht
der denn etwas persönlich seien könnte
nicht das ist das ist ein duell nicht
der andere gewinnt
ach ja und natürlich den sonst im sonst
machen sie es nicht dann bleiben sie
lieber zu haben das ist es ist ihnen zu
recht auch natürlich immer viel respekt
entgegen gekommen weil sie etwas
außergewöhnliches immer wieder gemacht
haben aber es kann manchmal schon die
kritik sie inszeniert sich ist war die
total falsch die kritik ich verstehe die
kritik nicht und ich spüre auch eine
gewisse eifersucht nicht aber ich habe
nichts dagegen nicht jeder kann sagen
also wähle die journalisten schreiben
was sie wollen aber ich meine ich bin
ein offenes buch also man kann genau
sehen objektiv genau sehen was weiß ich
und andere gemacht haben und dann kritik
die resultate sieht da also zu den
riddick geärgert haben sie überhaupt
gelesen was in den zeitungen so auch ich
hatte sogar eine pressesprecherin also
die hat mich immer
im laufen in ihr geschrieben nachgehen
sie haben die journalisten nicht so
richtig gemacht in denen es kommt drauf
an denn ich habe auch die journalisten
sehr gerne gehabt wenn ich sie gebraucht
haben
denn manchmal haben wir eben
pressekonferenzen oder gar nicht
plötzlich wieder hatten eine eine nicht
eindringlichkeit und sind alle gekommen
nicht und das war fantastisch natürlich
andere male konnten wir die frage nicht
beantworten aber ich glaube es war
wichtig dass wir das ich eine
pressesprecherin hatte das satire
das hat mir jegliche unannehmlichkeiten
mit gehalt und manchmal geben sie offen
zu haben die journalisten auch nützlich
weiß nicht ob das ein kompliment für die
journalisten ist aber okay damit wir
wollten nicht als zeuge auftreten wir
hatten manchmal einige schwierigkeiten
wir wollten ein paar journalisten als
zeugen in unserem prozess und auftritten
im ausland jetzt ex jugoslawien diagonal
nicht und da hatten wir schwierigkeiten
rumhacken wie sie wollen
die wollten nicht wegen pressefreiheit
oder wegen was
gut das ist natürlich hofft ein
wichtiges kriterium dass man seine
quellen nicht aufdecken konnten sie
verstehen ein bisschen gerne sowohl
kommen zu stehen
jeder hat dann auch trotzdem die
notwendigkeit die sie den journalisten
zu haben
und wenn ich mich nicht gut erinnern am
schluss konnten wir ihn doch jetzt hat
in einer creme und machen ist denn und
und und und und also wie gesagt dann
sind sie nachdem sie vom tessin aus die
mafia gejagt hatten sind die
bundesanwältin geworden
1994 daten sie mit dem journalisten auch
nicht immer nur die friedlichsten
verhältnisse sie haben mal eine razzia
bei der sonntagszeitung das laden dann
schwierige zeiten aber nicht wegen den
journalisten ja nachziehen da eine
durchsuchung habe man der freien presse
ja aber das hat nichts zu tun mit der
freien presse
jetzt ich erinnere mich nicht mehr genau
aber die durchsuchung war absolut legal
und wie ich glaube die sind natürlich
haben sie rekurriert gegen einen
entscheidenden entscheiden
bestätigt wurden also gemäß gesetz haben
sie kein schlechtes gewissen wenn ich
über die straße
ich habe mich mit dem gesetz sehr stark
geschützt und das gesetz nicht mehr
geschützt wenn es gesetzlich okay war
dann war genau wie keine anderen
überlegungen eben ich mache keine
politische überlegung ich mache kann
ökonomische überlegungen denn sonst bin
ich eben nicht unabhängig nicht
sonst schau ich schon auf dem fenster
zuerst du bist schön oder schlechtes
wenn die stimme des gesetzes gebe das
muss man nichts sonst
natürlich
aber ich habe viel gelernt bundesanwalt
in den kontakt mit politik war natürlich
sehr stark richtung der bundesstaaten
und golder hat mich mehrmals ins büro
gerufen gesagt was machen ziehen danach
warf sie zurück wenn nicht dann wollen
sie einfach genau wissen um was es geht
und an welchen politischen hauptstadt
will er entgegen
ich komme werde arbeitet ich bin mit dem
himmel sehr gut ausgekommen und es
verstanden und manchmal natürlich unter
de la mora ich werde mich dann haben wir
wieder hat denn ein verfahren über käse
der europäischen union käse käse
business und er hat mich angerufen im
café gegeben und gesagt wenn es soweit
kommt mit dieser bürger mit blue drohte
der schweiz eine busse von 120 millionen
hätten betrat sie treffen einen
entscheid als bundesrat
ich bringe das schriftliche entscheid in
meinem dossier und wir gehen nicht
weiter aber ihr müsst politisch auf dem
könnte es machen
gemäss gesetz aber ich brauche eben
diesen entscheid des bundes wie sind sie
was der entscheid des bundesrates ist es
nie gekommen
es ist etwas gekommen einen entscheid
dass der bundesanwalt keine rechtshilfe
ersuchen nach der europäische union
schicken konnte also und sie haben es
limitiert und ich glaube sie sind käse
geschichte ist nichts herausgekommen
glaube ich war das nicht anders nur um
zu sagen wie wie die politik enthalten
muss mir ihnen das offenbar gelungen ist
als sie dann 99 weggingen als
bundesanwältin um chefanklägerin bei der
uno zu werden ich vermute da haben wir
auch viele champagner korken und ein
paar billige main
borken man sagt ja ich freue mich wenn
sich an beiden getrunken haben die
schweizer wagen können die andere noch
ich freue mich denn ich alleine eine
wunderbare karriere machen können nicht
als progressiv sie waren als
bundesanwältin fehlen bemerkt wie man
auf amerikanisch sagt sie haben die
leute so richtig gestört und das sagen
sie das musste ich ja tun aussagen
sollten ich meine wir haben ich und
meine mitarbeiter nicht man muss nicht
vergessen ist nicht eine person allein
es ist eine eine gruppe also mit mit bei
der bundes sollen schafft haben wir da
natürlich die bundesanwaltschaft
reorganisiert mehr kompetenzen
und es funktionierte wir haben unsere
zuständigkeit ausgeweitet ausgeweitet
und sehr gefalle und natürlich wenn wir
die die organisierte kriminalität
bekämpfen wollen müssen
die frage war die frage kommt jetzt auch
noch öffentlich
wir sehen also das sag ich im positiven
sinne sie sind als mädchen schon
ambitiös hinter schlangenjagd gewesen
denn als junge staatsanwältin in bercy
akt haben sie diesen posten als uno
chefanklägerin angestrebt um noch
weiterzukommen noch nicht doch nicht
aber auch als bundesanwalt ich nie
geträumt dass ich bundesanwältin werde
aber auf einmal telefonisch bundesrat
kohle und sagt sind sie einverstanden da
da da hab ich das sagt ja gut ich bleibe
beim nicht sind sie anzufangen
bundesanwältin jahre habe ich weiß nicht
und nein ich habe nichts zu ich sofort
ja gesagt ich komme nach bern ich gehe
nach mehr
und dann sage ich ihm ja wie lange haben
lassen sie mir bis ich eine woche noch
ist nicht viel aber dann habe ich
gemeint gut ich bleibe staatsanwälte des
bundes anmelden damit sowie der stadt
sein wird
das einzige was ich machen kann
eigentlich also habe ich ja gesagt das
gleiche miete der uno chefanklägerin
staatssekretär
damals war das kelemen telefoniert die
wahl entweder zwar im august können wir
deinen namen spenden an die
chefanklägerin bei der uno habe ich
chancen habe gesagt absolut nicht die
schweiz ist nicht in ordnung die schweiz
ist nicht die nato der staatssekretär
sagte schauen sie in einer visa gut
spielt dann seien ja warum sollen die
den namen spendenjagd die politiker
seien politik schweiz es ist gut zu
sehen als auch nicht nach einer woche
sagt mir dass ich nach new york muss um
governor zu begegnen und der hat mir
auch nur eine woche gegeben zu
entscheiden dann konnte ich nicht einmal
nach den haag gehen und dann mal wissen
woran ich gehen aber eben mit dem
gleichen prinzip ja darüber staatsanwalt
eigentlich ist heisst es chefankläger
dieses staatsanwalt also sage ich ja und
auf einer noch wichtigeren größeren
bühne die bühne der ganzen welt so habe
ich nicht eigentlich gedacht nein ich
habe mir nur gedacht ich bleibe
staatsanwälte eine staatsanwältin die
dann kriegsverbrecher jagen musste wie
was bei
zurück von dieser erfahrung das war das
erste mal dass man sogar nach einem
präsidenten regierenden präsidenten in
der person von milosevic gesucht habt
hatten sie gespürt das ist jetzt eine
große historische mission was wir hier
machen
es war eine historische mission für
internationale justiz
das waren wie sicher ich und meine
mitarbeiterin im sicherheitsrat wenn man
diesen tribunal geschafft hat und man
nicht daran gedacht dass es ein erfolg
gewesen wäre aber ein alibi
politisch war lässt wichtiges zu machen
und darum die die unsere motivation
waren noch größer
es muss ein erfolg wird natürlich
besonders am anfang gut zu mir waren
zwei andere chefankläger der jetzt.de
nur ein jahr und dann die kanadierin
drei jahre und dann kann ich also das
erste was ich gemacht habe ist auch eine
reorganisation nicht und und dann wollte
sie auf dem posten abend das ist aber
sicherheitsrat die großen mächte
entscheiden weiß man wer für sie war von
vorne weg
das weiß ich nicht das weiß ich nicht
aber das ist auf antrag von kofi annan
genau generalsekretär und ich glaube es
waren die anonymität
alle wollten mich ja und dann kamen sie
haben ja organisiert hier bin ich die
schlangen ja gering wir machen das
anders
ja und das haben wir gemacht und konnten
wir doch dazu bringen 191 161
angeklagten alle verhaftet jetzt alle
verhaftet worden
auch nachdem ich nicht mehr dort war es
natürlich nicht aber die strategie die
wir aus gearbeitet haben hat erfolg
gehabt und das freut mich und das war
von beginn weg das ziel man es gibt sehr
viele täter in so einem konflikt in
diesen in der jugoslawischen
bürgerkriegen haben wir hat man gesagt
wir wollen die chefetage noch ein
wiesmann auf die 163 gekommen eigentlich
war es mehr als 300 in unsere liste
nicht als sich angefangen habe aber
wissen sie es steht im rom statut der
chefankläger ist unabhängig bestimmt
nicht schlecht denn natürlich hängt vom
von der finalen von den finanzen nicht
ist man auch geld um die zu jagen
es braucht viel geld und auf einmal
sicherheitsrat hat uns wissen lassen
jetzt müsst ihr jetzt aber weniger also
ihr müsst in wenigen jahren fertig
machen dann haben wir eine komplette
strategie labor ist nicht und dann haben
wir nur unsere minister reduziert denn
ich erinnere mich dass einmal in einem
jahr hat man unsere unsere monatslöhne
nicht bezahlt denn man hat von mir
gesagt wir haben kein geld mehr nicht
und dann natürlich generalsekretär hat
dann besorgt dass die dass die löhne
bekommen aber sie haben geld aber mit
mehr geld hätten sie mehrere
verhaftungen natürlich wenn wenn mir wir
hätten mehrere natürlich haben sie
gefragt nach mehr geld
wir haben gefragt
nach einem mädel sagte nicht nach geld
wir fragten nach dem besuch sind die wir
brauchen um diese angeklagten verhaften
zu lassen und die prozesse durchzuführen
und so weiter und so weiter dabei als
sich eine spezielle abteilung für die
verhaftung zusammen setzen wollte
denn wieder haben mehrmals unsere
angeklagten lokalisiert da bin ich die
die staaten haben dann sie nicht
verhaftet sie hat eine eigene polizei
wie sie dahin china eben nicht wollten
eine gruppe nicht von polizisten
zusammenstellen die nun wird die jagd
der und new york abgesagt
ich begann ist richtig ich nicht meine
polizei gewandt und darum wurde es
richtig politisch wenn sie jemanden
lokalisiert haben die lodge ist karadzic
ist dort was haben sie getan dann
mussten sie verhandeln und in ihrem buch
sprechen sie auch schon eine einem
unikum einer gummiwand in die sich
hinein geschlagen haben es war schon mal
einmal ging sie zum geschäft ändert in
washington und der hat sogar ziemlich
unhöflich gesagt eide und gif wir wollen
es ja nicht aussprechen aber die hatten
ziemlich deutlich werden ja doch also
moda donna ist wirklich ein guter ein
guter begriff nicht in worten in
baustellen jahr in fakten nichts nichts
gemacht geredet aber nichts gemacht nein
aber wir sind sie wir haben nie
nachgelassen
also sind wir regelmäßig wieder szenen
haben wir uns wäre und wie gesagt
gepresst und es wird genau da hat
unseren ruf stand ihnen dann doch etwas
genützt waren sie vielleicht manchmal
auch etwas zu forsch das schreiben sie
auch im buch das sie dem ci chef vor
seinen leuten irgendwie gesagt haben na
jungs jetzt aber mal ran also ein
bisschen die leviten gelesen das machen
will ich rede nämlich jetzt nicht mehr
dabei ist es möglich dass ich denn ich
erinnere mich dass ich diese
diese meeting e mail angefangen haben in
dem ich gesagt haben ich bin keine
diplomatin ich bin prosecutors o ich
spreche jetzt ganz offen vielleicht
manchmal einen seite mehr herausgeholt
vielleicht wenn man ein bisschen
diplomatischen wer weiß man
normalerweise nicht wissen sie wenn denn
in der politischen zeit liegt ganz oben
und je nachdem
ich weiß nicht ob özil aber ich kann
nicht
das ist nicht ihre instrumente
sie gingen aber auch nach ganz oben
damals war in den usa die stärkste
weltmacht natürlich war george bush am
drücker den haben sie zum beispiel
getroffen konnten wie war das metall
konnten sieben beeinflussen
bush präsident bush habe ich nicht
in washington getroffen habe der holland
auf einem friedhof in militärischen
amerikanischen friedhof denn es war eine
zeremonie der stunde ich war eingeladen
und die ich war befreundet mit dem
amerikanischen botschafter gesagt ich
komme auf dem friedhof aber notwendig
ein meter also jeden treffen kann nicht
das sollte man vielleicht weiß aber
schlussendlich konnte er war sympathisch
er hat mich auf die auf die hand
gedrückt und gesagt karadzic den werden
den wirt verhaft carla nannte mich kalt
er wusste nicht viel über caravaggio
wusste er was wäre mir sagen sollte
sollte nicht aber dann habe ich die dem
ministerin die auch 16 minister im
gesehen nicht warum das euro für das war
die frau als rossi condoleezza rice
ich habe sie gesehen dass sie dennis
eignete sich kalt und diese ist weg von
manfred oben und ich bin nicht
nachgegangen und plötzlich ist sie
ohnehin in den wagen eingestiegen
und natürlich wollte ich ja auch
internet wagen einsteigen aber die sind
alle bodyguard sind an das war ganz
unten
zum glück hat mir einen erkannte den rat
ist gott für mich gemacht in san diego
oder dem gesandte des erbes ich muss mit
ihm sprechen mit einem ministerium dann
hat einfach die türe geöffnet etwas
gesagt und mich hinein gelassen
diese reise mich plötzlich sachen
gesprochen darüber bin ich nicht gemacht
dann gab es einen innenpolitischen
faktor in serbien ein junger politiker
der in deutschland philosophie studiert
hat fließend deutsch sprach zoran
djindjic der damen der opposition groß
geworden ist mutig war ich weiß es er
hat uns im 10 14 und in der tagesschau
auf deutsch interviews gegeben
das hat die stimmung doch gewechselt den
serben mit dem haben sie dann intensiv
zusammengearbeitet
er konnte er etwas bewirken ja leider
wurde ermordet
ancic waren der einzige in den einzige
richtige mutige richtige mann würde ich
zukunft von serbien nicht und das ist
schade dass wir das sehr getötete denn
es hätte so gut getan für sein werk
wurde gute premierminister nehmen dann
hat er mit ihnen gearbeitet und und und
so geheimtreffen gemacht nicht am
flughafen in amsterdam an wir uns einmal
getroffen
einmal haben wir uns in den vereinigten
staaten getroffen
natürlich kontakt mit der opposition für
uns war es sehr wichtig nicht aber er
waren dauernde phase sie waren mit ihm
unterwegs war dass chris kommt ich werde
nicht mit ihm unterwegs wir trafen uns
eben inseln flughafen und sonst eher auf
der straße so und dann haben wir unsere
bodyguard weggeschickt und sind wäre ja
ein paar so herumgelaufen
denn er war vor allem nicht sehr sehr
aufgetragen war unvorsichtigen am
schluss er konnte auf offener straße
nein nein da schluss hinein sicher
nächste und ich erinnere mich ich hatte
ihm einen bericht gebracht dass das war
für einige wochen beförderer mord wird
wurde ein bericht von meinen leuten die
eben man wollte ihn töten in den er
hatte ein gips am fuß in gips am fuß
statt fußball gespielt mit der polizei
und man hatte ihm einen ball nicht bei
einer verletzung mann verletzungen am
fuß und in diesem bericht die sich für
die verletzung am fuß war absichtlich
den wänden aus dem aus durchstieg und
die zwei schritte zum haupteingang waren
dann langsam und so geschah es
aber als ich in dieses bericht gegeben
haben gesagt ja ich weiß ich weiß nein
einen seht gut wie ich jetzt schon so
weiter und so weiter
nachhilfe sind wir auch nicht mehr an
dieser stelle gewölbter berührte sind
wir mit dem wagen in den keller
aber sie müssen auch ich muss sehr
vorsichtig sein in serbien unterwegs
waren
doch dort lauert gefahr überall doch ich
glaube schon dass ich zwei oder drei mal
davon gekommen bin haben werde
einmal hat hat man geschossen auf meinen
wagen einmal allgemeinen autounfall auf
der autobahn dann hat dann hat man die
autobahn ein fachgeschäft von flughafen
wien gerade ich konnte nachts in den
bankrat ich musste sofort weg also doch
natürlich noch einmal darum die frage
auch da hat haben sie nie überlegt ist
ja kinder lohnt sich das soll man es tun
war die frage des risikos gar nicht mehr
präsent das einzige mal dass ich es
gemacht habe ist wenn der johanni
falcone getötet wurde und ich und meine
kolleginnen von
milano haben wir darüber gesprochen denn
da hab ich mich über liegt also ich
würde auf das wird zu gefährlich und so
weiter
damals war ich noch mafia aber nach
diesem gespräch mit dieser kolleginnen
haben wir nun so gesagt er ist nicht
mehr da also machen wir denn eigentlich
müssen wir ihm das und dann wenig weit
gehen und dann habe ich nie da
nein nein eigentlich nicht nein
jetzt machen sie es nicht mehr aber ich
habe das geht also sie machen ist noch
sie gehen mit
mit dieser kommission nach syrien der
vortrag den ich angesprochen habe war
gerade vor ihre syrien mission das ist
auch nicht ganz so eine richtige
gemütliche ferienreise sowas nein gar
nicht gar nicht dann so wenig geschlafen
viel gearbeitet
unglücklicherweise ist man hatte sie
nach der blutgruppe gefragt vor der
abreise ja für ikea ja das geschieht das
geschieht manchmal doch aber ich muss
sagen die schutzmaßnahmen bei den sehr
groß ist es ist alles gut gegangen und
konnten gut arbeiten also wir haben
viele gerade bei denen das programm
natürlich wenigen tagen müssen wir alles
viel 1 16 und ist auch nicht die
frustration mit all ihrer erfahrung zu
groß geworden
im heutigen syrien konflikt wie sehen
sie das könnte nicht die großmächte
präsident obama ein fortschrittlicher
posé präsident in washington
wenn er wollte oder musste er nicht mehr
tun damit etwas geschieht
ich muss ihnen sagen ich bin sehr
frustriert über serien auch schon im
begriff auf die justiz wir können nichts
machen also werde ich anklägerin würden
wie ich einige eine japanischen
vorbereitet ich habe die beweise also
nichts geschieht das ist eine große
frustration für mich und für die opfer
die ich tagtäglich je zehn in dieser
reise in dieser mission gesehen habe und
natürlich kann die internationale
gemeinschaft um sollte die
internationale gemeinschaft mehr tun
wir werden den wir haben jetzt in
unserem berichte der hitze im februar
herauskommt wir haben dort klar wort
gesprochen
also ich hoffe dass es zu einer
politischen lösung kommt ich hoffe dass
mehr für die auftritte gemacht wird dann
eine politische lösung für den ganzen
konflikt wüsste man wie das gehen würde
sie haben einen vorschlag den ich ja
eigentlich habe ich gar nicht verstanden
ich mache keine ob die kommission ich
keine wahl machen kann entkommen ist
auch die kommission hat keinen vorschlag
aber die kommission sagt warum das
geschehen muss und ich hoffe dass das
die zu spät denn die zustände sind so
tragisch so dramatisch jetzt ist
unglaublich dass heutzutage noch so
etwas passiert und und man nichts machen
und was ist ihre erklärung dass die welt
das einfach hinnimmt
ich habe eigentlich keine erklärung und
und besonders im bild im bezüglich
gerechtigkeit am justiz habe ich keine
erklärung den
sicherheitsrat und so gut reagiert und
in den balkan ist die rallye ohne ist
thema kambodscha überall man könnte ein
gericht machte sich natürlich ich weiß
nicht ich stehe russland nicht hatten
sie mit den russischen behörden auch
handelt
die die negieren negieren die realität
dass situation und und tun das ist
eigentlich politik leider ich glaube
heraus zu spüren dass sie durchaus
bereit wären wieder sich zu engagieren
und würden sie wieder wenn das gefragte
als anklägerin jetzt auch für syrien
natürlich könnte ich es machen denn ich
kenne die beweise die wir gesammelt habe
nicht ich weiß wie man dazu kommt dabei
hoffe dass andere junge leute das machen
können nicht ich arbeite noch gerne wäre
ich ruhe auch wenn jetzt wo sie zeit
haben für die einnehmen diesem golf
spielen und es mir nicht vorstellen aber
auch da ist das auch schön sehr schön
wenn sie sagen zurückblicken beruflich
gesehen wann waren sie auch am
glücklichsten was war das befriedigende
für sie sehen sie so ambitiös bin ich
damit ich kann nicht sagen wann er denn
für mich ist arbeit ist routine arbeit
mit vielen nicht mit viel engagement man
muss zum saisonstart kommen aber heute
könnte ich ihnen nicht sagen wann war
vielleicht das nicht belastet wurde und
in den haag das jahr eine große freude
und ich und meine kollegen meinem büro
und das ein bisschen wir feiern gibt es
nicht schon beim champagner sowie ein
schlechtes rotes leinen in papiere
gläser rahmen der aber doch angestoßen
habe das ganze war ein höhepunkt das
könnte man nicht sagen öffentlich den es
ist nicht gut ja ja wir haben es doch
gemacht denn umgekehrt als er dann in
der haft start das noch warm zog sich so
nach hin und da hin
das hat sie richtig getroffen dann dass
er herum
warum es mich getroffen hat ja wir sind
sie tausende von opfer warteten auf
gerechtigkeit und das wurde jetzt weil
er
und das für dich also unterhalt schon
einige probleme mit meinem gott ja also
das jetzt noch so wie ein engel im bett
gestorben ist und tun das ist was mich
gewählt
natürlich auch ich war bereit meine
anklage rede zu eröffnen nicht der
präsidenten der den prozess zu eröffnen
und das habe ich dann wegwerfen können
in der westlichen kultur ist ja der tod
angelegte summe um mal um das
schlechteste was einem widerfahren kann
milosevic war nie mehr frei gekommen
warum was muss es bringen diese
strafjustiz vergeltung damit die opfer
naja ob wieder ski oder reue
nein in der nur für die opfer rache nein
nein nein aber wenn die haupt das ist
das ist wirklich sehr sehr wichtig meine
letzte frage ist haben jetzt zeit und
scheint es zu genießen auch mit ihren
enkelkindern zu spielen werden die wenn
sie mal groß sind in einer viel
gerechteren welt legen als wir jetzt ich
bin ein optimist in der natur und muss
sagen ich hoffe ich hoffe sie aber wenn
ich jetzt schauen wie ist auf der welt
geht muss ich sagen etliches muss
gemacht werden damit es soweit möchten
aber wie gesagt
wir müssen die hoffnung behalten carla
del ponte vielen dank für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen dankeschön nächste woche
reden wir in der sternstunde philosophie
über die medien wer die wahrheit sagt
braucht ein schnelles pferd sagt ein
chinesisches sprichwort möchten sie da -
moderatorin chinas staatsfernsehen sein
oder bilden vielleicht wir uns im westen
zu viel auf unsere pressefreiheit ein
darüber spreche ich mit einer
chinesischen und einer türkischen star
nachrichten journalistin am nächsten
sonntag für heute bedanke ich mich sehr
fürs zuschauen einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]